all right our next speaker is kevin chan
he's going to talk about it methods and
high dimensional stats
well uh hi everyone thanks for coming to
my talk so um i'm kevin i'm a fellow for
the uh gmail program this semester i'm
also a
final year grad student at stanford um
and i'd like to tell you about some uh
recent collaborations of mine that fit
broadly under the theme of creative
methods and high dimensional stats
okay so in a few buzz words uh i like to
describe my research goal as identifying
fundamental algorithmic challenges in
modern data science
and solving them scalably reliably and
accurately so these are very fuzzy terms
and i'd like to be a little bit more
more concrete what i mean
by scalable i mean i i like to consider
algorithms that perform well on uh on
large data sets so namely uh with fast
runtimes i ideally nearly linear sub
linear
operating under common oracle uh model
access and uh flexible in terms of the
models of computation they run on so
namely parallel or streaming settings
okay uh by reliable i mean i'd like to
assume as little as possible the problem
uh and design frameworks which are uh
flexible namely they don't like overfit
to the particular problem and this is
also captured by things like uh
misspecification robustness
and finally i care about accurate
methods so namely i like algorithms
which have um ideally like very very
strong optimization performance uh
strong statistical rates so namely like
the um the error rate and the uh the
sample complexity things like this
uh and finally i like to understand uh
what what it means to be optimal uh in
the form of lower bounds
okay cool
so um this talk is more about the
techniques that uh that are that i
commonly encounter in terms of facing
these uh big data computational tests
so in particular i draw upon two fields
uh
techniques so the first is what i like
to refer to as iterative methods uh
namely how do i manipulate the data
efficiently so this comes in the form of
tools from continuous optimization and
uh more classical algorithm design such
as numerical linear algebra data
structures things like this
um on the other hand uh in order to
obtain true uh like truly optimal
methods statistically it often uh you
have to often understand the structure
of the data so uh namely this is high
dimensional statistics where you draw
upon things like uh geometric uh
properties of the data concentration
phenomena and so on
um
and in fact uh many problems in modern
data science benefit from understanding
the toolkits of each of these particular
fields but to obtain sort of the best of
all worlds often you have to uh have a
careful interplay between
the uh the techniques of both
so um i guess these are sort of like a
broad overview of the topics that i'm
i'm interested in have worked on to some
extent so if you if you like any of
these i'm sure we have things to chat
about but uh for this talk i'd like to
focus on two in particular um which
really capture the interplay between
these two uh sets of techniques
okay so the first half will be about
logging of sampling and the second half
will be about a robust estimation
okay so uh diving right into it uh we're
going to consider the problem of
composite log to give sampling where uh
just as an example you might try to draw
a
a sample from a multivariate normal
distribution i'll subject to box
constraints on the uh on the parameters
so namely you can think of these as like
parameter ranges for each of your each
of your dimensions
so um
introducing a little bit more more
notation
um this is the problem of drawing a
sample from a density proportional to
minus f minus g
where f here captures the uh the
multivariate normal part and g is the
restriction to a box namely it's zero
inside the box and infinity uh
everywhere else okay
so um a generalization of this problem
is uh the following setup where f is
some nice function
and g is sufficiently simple but
possibly non-smooth
here you should think like f is like the
multivariate gaussian it captures some
something about your generative model
like it's uh it's like you think your
data is being drawn from some gaussian
or um like a multi-logic distribution
um and g is supposed to capture some
sort of prior information about your
parameters so namely maybe you think
it's sparse uh you enforce an l1
constraint or you think it has certain
parameter range this is the box
constraint
okay cool so in order to sample from
this problem uh drawing inspiration from
this uh recently explored connection
between optimization and sampling uh the
first thing someone might hope to do is
to draw inspiration from composite
optimization so just to give you a
reminder of how these methods typically
work um when you're just trying to
minimize apps which is well conditioned
you typically just like repeatedly call
a minim a minimizer to an approximation
of f and the idea is equal better and
better approximations
um however when uh when the function
you're trying to optimize is not smooth
perhaps you uh you don't have access to
such a nice approximation but it
suffices to just approximate the wall
condition part and then exactly call an
oracle to minimize g this is proximal
methods
and the key sort of idea is uh g
simplicity is reflected in the existence
of a proximal orbit where you can
minimize a quadratic approximation plus
all of t
okay cool
so in sampling worlds one might try to
pattern pattern a method off of this
where instead of drawing samples from
the negation of x of
f plus g you might try to draw samples
from an approximation of f minus g and
the hope is that by calling this oracle
repeatedly you can you can sample from
the original function as well
um and here the sort of notion of
simplicity you might hope for is the
existence of a restricted gaussian
oracle where you can draw samples from a
gaussian restricted by this function g
okay
so uh this problem has actually been uh
reasonably well studied but perhaps
surprisingly strategies of this form
aren't known to yield rates that are uh
stronger than general purpose logical
samples uh so this is sort of like a uh
a notoriously tricky uh
gapped bridge between the optimization
and sampling setups
okay
so to extend upon these ideas we we drew
inspiration from um these hamiltonian
methods in sampling
and the idea of hamiltonian methods is
typically to introduce this dual
velocity variable uh and on this like uh
expanded space this the dynamics have
some nice properties such as time
reversibility and things like that i
won't go into too much detail here
but um it turns out that this
hamiltonian approach has uh really nice
implications for composite sampling in
particular by expanding the space to be
2d dimensional d-dimensional and
considering this joint density which
couples the two um you can use the the
the dual variable to control the
stability of this overall um
uh density
and in particular to sample from this
you just have to show that the thing is
close to the original which smoothness
of f will allow you to do and then
alternation schemes devices for the um
for the joint density
okay so uh under the hood what's going
on is a is sort of this novel novel
sampling framework which uh which
generalizes hmc and has implications for
all manners of
uh structured densities
what condition composite finite sum and
so on
so i thought this is like a cool uh
exposition of how combining ideas from
high dimensional statistics and
iterative methods yields uh new
algorithms
okay so um
uh switching gears a little bit i like
to tell you about a problem uh in robust
estimation i've also worked on called
listed decodable mean estimations
so in the typical uh majority in-layer
setting for robust statistics typically
um the classical setting asks you to
perform estimation where you have access
to a data set drawn for some nice
distribution namely estimate the mean
um in the robust setting you assume that
part of your data set is contaminated
and in fact not uh not in liars so john
some adversary gives you some additional
data points
okay
uh and the goal here is typically either
to
perform estimation in the um in the
presence of outliers or to uh identify
who the outliers are okay and in the
high dimensional setting where the data
set is supported on say rd for um d very
large
uh this is this is a somewhat
challenging problem but recent
breakthroughs show you could perform
various types of estimation in
polynomial time
so the the problem i want to talk about
today is what's known as the majority
outlier model of robust statistics where
here you assume that an alpha equals 1
over k fraction of your data set is
drawn from the nice distribution but
here k is like much larger than two
namely a a large uh small minority of
your data set uh is is nice
and the remaining fraction of your data
set is totally arbitrary and given to
you by an adversary and the question is
what does it even mean to perform
estimation in this uh in this in this
model
so it turns out that uh that sort of
like the information theoretically
rightful is to output a list of
hypotheses one of which is close to the
um the uh the estimate of the parameter
that you're trying to estimate so um
yeah it's very uh straightforward to see
that like otherwise it's sort of like
not identifiable
okay
so this uh this model is very flexible
and has a lot of applications in um
various settings you might want to
consider including crowdsourcing graph
inference and clustering mixture models
i won't go into it too much here but um
yeah please follow us straight forward
corollaries
okay
so to tackle this problem uh the first
thing we tried to do was build a uh a
new uh simpler polynomial time method
which really captures the geometry of
mixture models um in terms of how it's
how it's designed so previous algorithms
for this problem uh that random
polynomial time typically have very long
analyses and were somewhat
non-transparent so the first goal was to
like come up with a very concise
algorithm for this problem um so here's
the entire algorithm
it solves uh solves it nearly optimally
in polynomial time
and i won't go into it too much but for
those familiar with the uh majority in
liar setting line seven and eight are
the standard like soft iterative
downloading procedures which is common
to most uh robust statistics in that
model
but sort of everywhere else in the
algorithm we had to design new like
termination conditions uh a new scoring
system a new like uh sampling method uh
which really captures uh the geometry of
mixture models and is inspired by it
okay
so the second question you might ask is
okay polynomial time is great but i i
tried to promise that i would give fast
methods so can we can we do better
um and it turns out you can reduce this
problem to nearly linear time uh using
ideas from fast stp machinery so this
requires the development of new um stp
tools mainly like custom chi fan regret
um founds
and uh
in order to cope with the difficulties
that come with these like modifications
to the uh to the algorithmic framework
we had to sort of like really open up
every part of this chi fan regret
analysis and say okay maybe not
everything won't go quite as smoothly as
you wanted but any time it does you have
some other reason to terminate the
outgroup so this is sort of like a a
real like coupling of the high
dimensional stats tools in the united
states
okay
um and so the first the first work in
this series uh reduced the the runtime
of this overall algorithm to a poly
logarithmic number of um of kpca calls
where k is like the
inverse fraction of good guys
and uh since then we've been able to
open it up a little bit more and improve
the whole thing
okay awesome yeah thanks so much for
coming to my talk and hopefully uh
number seven
all right
so
our next feature is